never heard them talk about plot ever
they talked about characters and
conflict
can you explain the three elements of a
hollywood pitch well i'll start
um
[Music]
the the first thing is a hook
because
so you have to have a premise we we've
talked about this many times in the book
um
so
the first way though the first way in in
my experience and what we talk about in
the book is
you have to start with a sentence that
hooks people and uh um peter will you
tell them one that comes from carol
carol
carol's pitch carol hafner's pitch
about
the girl who leaves school for a year
i love that i think it's an excellent
example
i'm
i can do it i'm not sure i'll get the
wording exactly right it doesn't matter
sometimes you learn more
if you don't go to school
right so it's called leap year
or gap year i'm sorry it's called gap
year leap year's a whole amy adams movie
that
so you start with that because that is
that may be as far as you'll get
if they don't like so it's one or two
sentences at most
it gives you a sense of
what the
theme or the story might be about
and then if you're lucky
you go to the log line that's that which
um i'm sure a lot of people have talked
to you about but quick questions sure my
objection is
um
as a
as a boring psychologist which i guess
is redundant um
one of the things we look at a lot is
the principle of primacy
the thing you hear first is the thing
you remember best
and
there's hundreds and thousands of
studies i give somebody a list of items
to buy at the market
they always remember the first one it's
just what we do right and so the first
thing you hear is very important
and so if you can get that very first
thing to be something that rattles
around in their cortex and stays with
them because it's clever and it gives
you some sense of where you're going
that's going to help guide them all the
way through
i'll give you another example because we
use it all the way through the book and
that's the odd couple probably the best
american comedy written in the latter
half of the 20th century and i would say
and we know this because everybody
copies it
um hopefully they make it their own when
they copy it like i was thinking about
mom which was a great show but it's the
odd couple
so
peter came up with a great uh because
neil simon didn't have to write hooks
and log lines because he was famous and
successful by the time he wrote the odd
couple
but
the the hook that peter came up with
saving your best friend's life could
kill you
that's a great hook because it makes you
want to hear more
and that's the whole purpose and
it goes with that principle of privacy
i'm going to remember that that's going
to stay in my head and and it's an
anomaly which which makes it a little
more powerful and it's a little poetic
too which is nice so now tell them the
premise of the odd couple which is that
i mean i'm sorry the log line the the
next step please this is oh i um
i don't know if i ever told you this you
can cut this you know my dad produced
the odd couple so i i have a personal
attachment to the tv show
which i always thought was the best of
all of the
versions
um
where were we oh longline
getting old as hell um you've got that
um
so so it's the um the the
neatest guy in the world
moves in with the sloppiest guy in the
world they have all the same
problems they did with their wives
and what what am i missing from that
there is something missing
no no i think that's that's just just
say a divorced company to i'm sorry i
didn't say divorce the
the
divorce men
the sloppiest guy in the world and the
neatest guy in the world move in
together and have all the same problems
they had with their wives that's the
that's the log line
i hope you can cut around this
[Laughter]
would you say laverne and shirley was
enough yes absolutely
complete and
because gary marshall
who was penny's brother
had produced the odd couple so
i'm sure that i mean
the thing is it's been you know when i
say it's used i mean i think
the really best ones certainly two and a
half men is
you know which is not a show i've ever
loved but um
but that's certainly the odd couple you
know it's two brothers and they couldn't
be more desperate so
you know
we told you this in a previous interview
but we have a flair for repetition
um
in other words we forget things
that when jeffrey and i were writing our
book interviewing comedy writers we were
saying do you think these writers are
going to go more because they're
creating stuff on the spot we said are
they going to go more for character or
they're going to go for story first
and we found out that the answer was
neither
they went for conflict
all comedy all
any any kind of entertainment no
conflict no story and so the nice thing
about the log line is right away you're
hit with here's the major conflict and
you can see put two people like this
together and they're going to approach
every situation from diametrically
opposite points of view so the conflict
is constantly inevitable right
and
and that you can see it as you're
listening you can already see
all the ways you're going to have
confidence in any like any good story it
grows you know you know it's going you
think it's going one place like the andy
story
but you can't see the end and that's
what you want you really don't want
people to know
where it's going the minute they know
where it's going in my experience and
i'm sure peter has a similar experience
and we've had it together is the minute
they know it's going it's an i i think
it's an automatic no yeah we heard that
um
details are really important
right and i know this is a cliche
example and we've we've been told you
know this is overused but sunset
boulevard is one of your favorite movies
it is my favorite okay okay right
basically yeah and
that that if you were to pitch it you
said you would use you would pitch it
based on the characters always come from
the characters and conflict
um that's what we learned um so you know
when
i i think sometimes in film schools
i think it's changing
structure structure structure is taught
first and
maybe it's because of how i grew up and
who i grew up around i never heard them
talk about plot ever they talked about
characters and conflict
a couple of the people
who we interviewed
in that book are no longer with us they
were like like sherwood schwartz
you know but you brought up the brady
bunch
um i i don't think uh he or leonard uh
stern talked about
they talked about conflict and they
talked about what would the character do
and what do they want
and in every scene i think this doesn't
get talked about enough is um what do
they want not just in the whole
arc of a story what do they want in each
scene
um
and
i think
and what's in their way
and that's conflict
and and when in the case of norma
desmond what what is she doesn't i mean
to boil it down she wants to make a
comeback
and i think what's underneath that and
what makes it you know and people don't
realize that it's a satire and that's
why they got so angry in hollywood when
it came out you know louis v mayer jack
warner threatened they said you've
you're trading and they said to billy
wilder you're training on the industry
that has fed you and created you
they didn't realize it was a satire
you know because it's all so tragic
but yeah i mean
she wants she doesn't she doesn't want
to be passed she she's writing that
script which
william holden describes as drek
you know
and she thinks that's going to be her
comeback
and i'm happy to say i've never seen the
musical
because um
i didn't want to spoil the experience of
the film